first nomination I know I mean how are
we doing tonight I couldn't believe I
was nominated for a Grammy for best
comedy album I mean I woke up and I I
got a text from one of my agents and I
told him I was nominated for Grandma and
he goes for what
and I was like I don't know I have to
find out so yeah it's very exciting yeah
it's a good night it's a really good
night um first of all you guys
I love the love I know that you felt the
love back to you and I just I really
like there's a joy a lightness just you
know I don't know a free what is it I
don't know he melted me he melted me
somebody had to do it right exactly but
you know what it does show Kevin always
says to me like it doesn't come when we
necessarily want it we never really know
and it just hits you like it like yeah
yeah yeah we've been friends for so many
years so I was not expecting that and I
didn't always have those feelings but
when they hit me I was like whoa I
better find out what this is about and
then it became an emergency I can dig it
911
thank God I did yeah yeah wait it out
everybody wait it out well this is a
good date night so we do have to ask you
to because you're a comedian you saw
what happened over the last week I did
when when you think about that as a
comedian how do you wrap your brain
around it and what do you think I just
think Chris Rock handled himself was
such a plum and it's like such a pro and
that you know he couldn't have reacted
in a better way like he just handled it
like a professional and it was a it was
a good uh example to all performers and
all comedians how to keep your cool you
know and not be reactive and actually
keep the show moving along well he's my
king so just seeing him stand the way he
did and hold his composure man I love
him so much so yeah it made you all
think though because you're on stand-up
stage a lot and you're very vulnerable
does it work does it make you think
price do you say maybe I need to have
some people around me even more I don't
know yeah yeah well I mean we all have
security you know so yeah of course you
have to if you're a public person
especially if you're me
right remember you later there's some
folks but that's what we love about you
because you are you and you do the damn
thing and you really don't care well
yeah I try to uh yeah exactly you know I
mean you can't worry about the people
that don't you like you it's more
important to focus on the people that
you do that do like you and serve them
and serve them up with laughter and
you're you know the people who
appreciate you so yeah and when they
don't you can say I got a Grammy
nomination [ __ ]
that's what I'm going to say from now on
uh she's gonna win by the way she's
going to win I love it can we talk about
your movie too listen I forget about
that
DreamWorks thank you so much but it this
is her night oh
so I'll give you the plug Joe we gotta
give me
I don't get to see you often so when we
get to see you guys and see you guys
together we want to give you all the
flowers thank you for bringing an
incredible year together so yeah for
sure love brings out the best in
everybody right doesn't it doesn't it
yeah yeah he's on me because I'm newly
in and it's good
Chelsea but it's true but I'm a lot like
you you I think we're about the same age
too I think we're just even a couple
weeks apart
so there you go baby I'll talk to you
when I get there but I know what it's
like when you finally find that person
and it's just real and you're adults and
it's like the love is good and you're
not afraid to like just be in it and be
strong in it yeah it's everything it's
nice when a man can see a woman and just
I feel seen you know you somebody sees
everything about you and loves you in
spite of it you know and just you don't
have to shrink or make yourself less
intimidating or any of that I just like
having a woman when you walk in and
there's a confrontation that's about to
happen and I'm like she's going to take
care of this yeah she's got yeah yeah
I'm not gonna do this she's gonna handle
this yeah so that feels good baby listen
good luck tonight Chelsea take home that
great thank you guys thank you so much I
loved her before now she's like my
friend in my head
thank you so much
[Music]